Good morning, good afternoon, good
evening depending upon where you are in
the world as you watch this. Today we
thought we'd talk about something that
uh is actually at the very core of how
we've built the Gajimaru. We talked
about this in the past that we called it
the gajimaru because of this feature
which is that it has a common root group
the uh open governance-free resource
layer that sits at the bottom and allows
everything else all of the innovation to
really occur at the associate chain
level and associate chains in this
context are they don't actually have to
be blockchains they can be databases
they can be SQLs um but the idea really
is that we're recognizing that within
the the real world. We have sovereign
nations who have rules and regulations,
taxation and accounting practices that
need to be done to operate a business in
that jurisdiction. Um, so in reality,
the idea of associate chains is not just
that this pushes the innovation to that
level, it's also that it's recognizing
that there is a need for regulatory
oversight, uh, legislative oversight and
so on. Um around that we've seen a lot
of issues in the blockchain space where
on the one hand you have the likes of
Christine Lagard pointing the finger at
blockchain as being a tool for money
laundering whilst ignoring the trillions
of dollars that are facilitated through
the existing banking system which is
much more opaque which we can come to
when we talk about associate chains
because actually that opacity is lent to
it by the fact that they're a regulated
entity um and that's where that privacy
can come from. Now how they abuse that
is a whole other story which is not our
domain of expertise.
But um when we're looking at how
the realities of blockchain work that
everything is traceable unless you do
something to to to fudge that and we can
touch into some of those just tornado
cache tumblers and so on. But with that
having sort of set the scene, I'm going
to throw it over to Ulf to to reiterate
what the structure is between uh the
associate chains and the core the
resource layer. So this is working off
the um the pneummonic we use which is
ripper resource infrastructure platform
application as a tool set to understand
how blockchains actually work from that
core resource layer through to the point
of the application layer that we as
individuals interact with. Uh so Ol over
to you.
>> Yeah. Right. So we have talked quite a
lot about Groot and the fact that it's a
classic proofof work decentralized
blockchain. Um which we use to mint the
gaju as a universal resource. Um, we
haven't talked that much about associate
chains partly because we were for the
longest time waiting for some patent
applications to be filed and we couldn't
really talk much about certain details
before
um
before those had been registered
properly. Um so associate chains are
actually connected to the parent chain.
Uh at the top level it's going to be
grouped. the the connections are a
little bit different from gateways uh
typical blockchain gateways in that in a
couple of ways and uh most of them most
of those design decisions are
deliberate in order to make them easier
to regulate
because as we like to put it
decentralized proofof work blockchains
are regulation resistant. They
they make enforcement really hard. Um
they
offer something called pseudonymity.
It's like everything is essentially
transparent but also
uh privacy is really hard which we can
get into. Um
so with associate chains
the connection point anyone can create a
connection point for an associate chain.
Um
it has a list of approver accounts
essentially that anything that goes in
and out of the parent chain to the
associate chain has to be signed by a
majority of the associate chain
operators.
Um, we do not do
zero knowledge proof rollups or anything
because
our assumption is that
the
permissionless chain cannot be put in a
position to know too much about the
associate chain.
If the idea is that the responsibility
and the regulatory
compliance lies with the those who
operate the associate chain. So those
can be banks for example and uh to put
them into a position where they have to
comply with some complex mathematical
proofs on on the Groot is going to be
just make it so much harder to
to adopt them and it's actually not
going to provide much uh
much value in terms of commercial
utility.
So
essentially the operators are on the
hook if it's a regulated associate chain
and uh the operators are then typically
also known
but this also means that
like Greg said the associate chain can
be it can be a public chain. It can be a
public typically I guess a public
permission chain run by trusted
operators.
It could be a private chain or something
that just a acts like a chain in the
interface but is really say a legacy
banking system with a clever adapter on
it. And uh
so essentially it provides
the the environment where if you have
gajus on the parent chain,
it's a straightforward transaction to
move gajus from the parent chain into an
associate chain
into your account there transfer. Sorry,
let let me just pull you back a second a
little bit here because the use of the
word parent chain is is incorrect here I
think in that it's it's not a parent in
the classic sense as you see being used
in the context of uh polygon and um
cosmos
because that sort of implies to people's
ears it might imply that there is a um
an a supervisory connection from Groot
the resource layer to the infrastructure
structure layer, the associate chain,
that isn't the case. But there is a
specific thing that is different, which
is that they're aware of one another,
which is very different from
>> the likes of Cosmos and Poly uh
>> Polygon. Um I just want to be careful
because that those words a little bit
like
>> lots of these things they get
deliberately abused. So I want to be
careful that we don't create the um
perception in in for the viewer that
this is something akin to there is no
control function from group to the
associate chain
>> right um so you could you could see the
associate chain network as a hierarchy
where an associate chain can itself have
connected associate chains. H and
>> so for for example you could have um the
country of uh catmand do having an
associate chain and each of the banks
that run payment systems accounts etc as
regulated entities within that running
databases as associate chains within the
national blockchain framework for
example.
>> Yes. And and there are several reasons
why you might want to do this. Um
uh I mean one possibility is that the
national chain could implement its own
native currency that's that operates in
parallel with the gaju
uh and that the associate chains to that
chain in in uh its turn in their turn
they actually see the
uh the national chain as the minting
master of the native currency and
other reasons to I mean you could
see for example if if you're a bank and
you want to run an associate chain
um it could be a private chain that you
use to implement public banking
requirements where you selectively are
able to
uh reveal information in a way that's
compliant with uh with the laws and uh
but then allow
activity traceable activity on your
local chain. Now you could also create
an associate chain to scale out and have
uh dedicated performance on your chain
or dedicated characteristics
that for example even if
say you have a high volume traffic and
you or you have different response time
requirements
from from the root chain uh or from the
the chain you're connected to. I guess
it would
what would be the I mean you could say
superior chain too, but the as you say
the the parent chain or the superior
chain in the in the hierarchy
doesn't really control anything except
that it verifies that the subordinate
chain cannot print money. It cannot
create money out of thin air. So you
have to the amount of gajus you transfer
into that associate chain.
Well the amount of gajus that you pull
out of the associate chain can never
exceed the amount of gajus that you have
transferred into it.
>> This is that's the awareness point. Um
but in in fact let's say for example
Katmandeue were a country and Katmandeue
were to decide to implement uh some sort
of digital coin of their own they would
be the mint for that coin but they then
have an exchange issue where they would
need to go from that currency to another
let's say for example the catmand do
pound to the US dollar the transferring
uh vessel would be the guard you and
that would mean that although that you
could do that as an atomic swap because
we talked about this in the past with
the example of New Zealand and Canada
that if I were to transfer money from
New Zealand to Canada I would optimally
to do the exchange rate process I would
go New Zealand dollar to Australian
dollar, Australian dollar to Japanese
yen, Japanese yen to US dollar, US
dollar to Canadian dollar in order to
hit all the liquidity pools and actually
be able to transact and transfer in the
most efficient way.
bizarrely. Um whereas with the gaju, you
could go New Zealand dollar, gazu,
Canadian dollar because it creates that
global open resource layer in which all
of these things can interface. Um but
actually the transaction could be almost
atomic that you have New Zealand dollar,
gazu, Canadian dollar within the same
transactional block. episode occurs in
one movement as opposed to multiple
steps.
>> Right. Yeah. If a if a given AC if a
given associate chain was participating
in the Canadian dollar and the US dollar
or whatever or the Australian dollar and
the gaju then you have all three right
there. It's like
>> you know
>> well that would be permission Craig
because what we were saying in fact one
of the design aspects of the associate
chain was that
>> it is natively interoperable but
selectively interconnected by which we
mean that the group structure makes it
natively interoperable. But how an
associate chain chooses to permit those
within the chain to transact outside of
the chain and come into the chain or it
may not be a chain. It may just be an
SQL database that they run. But what can
come in and out of that pathway is
determined by their rules of
connectivity.
Right? So for example, if America had
its own national associate chain, it may
choose would choose to treat a Taiwanese
associate chain and Taiwanese dollar
differently from a Chinese associate
chain and a one or a
you can just keep rolling that analogy
across because each time where there are
different business ties, commercial
ties, sorry, uh commercial business
being the same, forgive uh political
ties, uh diplomatic ties, you're going
to see slightly different arrangements
between them as to what sort of
connectivity they will have. Um
so
let's let's come back to a more
fundamental thing uh and try and hone in
on this. What does a blockchain actually
do? An actual blockchain that actually
works. It allows us to trust the
message, not the messenger securely at
scale. Now what we have in the
traditional banking system is a process
where we trust the messenger. You trust
that Royal Bank of Scotland, uh, Bank of
Japan, um, Bank of America, Meil Lynch,
uh, whoever it is that this is a big
institution that you can trust. Why can
you trust them? Well, you know, they've
got brand u positioning and um a sense
of sanctity around them that they see as
fun or so they claim is fundamental to
their business case. Uh, of course that
changes when they it turns out that they
have taken their rent seeking position,
thoroughly abuse it to the point that
now they're going bankrupt and everyone
else has to bail them out. But we'll get
past that.
>> I was about to say, why do we trust
them? But it's fine.
>> Because we don't have choice. That's the
thing. Uh,
what's the other option? Going with
gold, physical gold, which is
>> well,
>> yeah. Well, look, why do we have
regulation? The answer to why we have
regulation is because there's an
imbalance of power between those who are
given the uh permission to act in a
trusted context to be the messenger that
we trust. And so the idea is in theory
that the regulator is the ally of the
the little guy who says, "Oh, hold on a
second. my bank has not accurately
maintained the ledger of my accounts and
I now need that to be fixed. That really
in theory is what regulation is supposed
to cover. It's supposed to give
asurances to the world that you can
trust these guys because not only do
they have this brand that is dependent
upon your trust, so they say, but in
addition to that, we're actually looking
at their accounts, we're supervising how
they segregate funds, how they manage
everything, how their databases are run,
and we can step in and fix this if it
turns out that there's a problem. And we
can hold them to ransom by saying, "If
you don't address this problem, we will
close down your banking license." Um, of
course that's a nuclear option, but
the point is
the existing financial system is
essentially a series of fractured and
fragmented infrastructures. Those who
get to run those infrastructures are
licensed entities. Those who connect
those infrastructures are licensed
entities licensed by a regulator or a
multiplicity of regulators. and they use
that regulated position essentially to
be rent seekers in the interconnection
and facilitation of trade. You're right,
we don't have an alternative choice,
Dimmitar, because as it stands, Bitcoin
is a wonderful proof of concept for a
peer-to-peer electronic cash system, but
it doesn't actually work as such.
Everything else is a fake blockchain. If
it's proof of stake, it's fake. That's
the simple rule. Anonymous proof of
stake is a gameable system and the
assumption that nobody's gaming it when
the actors involved are Binance,
Coinbase, uh, and Larry Frink is,
let's just say, hopelessly optimistic.
Um,
>> so I guess we could also as a fresh
example of this, we have the um
the recent verdict in uh the United
States where Roman Storm who was one of
the founders of Tornado Cash uh was
convicted for
I don't know what was it he was exactly
essentially uh conspiring to run uh
operate an unlicensed money transfer
operation
and um there has been a lot of confusing
publicity about that. Some have argued
that this is basically criminalizing
open-source development because all he
did was write some clever contracts that
could be used uh for privacy.
But
they actually did more than that. They
they uh launched a special coin and a
special ecosystem essentially on top of
uh blockchains uh like Ethereum to to
make it possible to um anonymize uh
money transfers or token transfers. And
as it happened, a lot of the activity
that
um a lot of the many of the actors that
actually used tornado cash were
criminals or
um
governments that
didn't necessarily want or wanted to
meddle in other government's affairs in
a way that was untraceable.
And um and a big aspect of why they were
convicted convicted what
um what's called willful acceptance that
they were actually making money on from
the torn coin and uh
they were making more money
as traffic increased
And
so when you profit from illegal activity
and you basically say that well that
wasn't my intention but hey this is kind
of cool
>> you are essentially on the hook legally.
>> Come back to something else that you
pointed out in the discussion on this
that we had prior to coming on to the
the the chat today. Um,
in actual fact, the Tron, oh, it's not
Tron, um, that's another discussion.
The, uh, Tornado Cash founders allocated
themselves very large amounts of the
staking token that ran the so-called
decentralized autonomous organization,
which we've touched on before, that the
vast majority of them are not
decentralized in any way, shape, or
form. They are merely a tool for
pretending that something is
decentralized in much the same way that
people are using so-called layer ones to
pretend that something is decentralized
when clearly they aren't. Salana
defininity for example.
Um
the
the egregious part in this was actually
that they did have governance. They had
control through the DAO of what could or
could not happen on the chain. it wasn't
governance-free. It wasn't open as has
been claimed. So that that that part is
an important component of what you
posted about this.
So arguably if you want to make
something that is actually useful
on a public decentralized chain, this is
what you need to do. You need to provide
some kind of platform on top that
that ensures that things are actually
working well and uh you you need to
market it. You need to probably attract
some investors. You need to make sure
that for example in the case of tornado
cache that you have relay agents that
are uh
that are you need to reach some volume
in order for it to be properly
anonymized and stuff like that. So you
actually have to work at creating an
ecosystem and then essentially you
cannot afterwards
claim that you have no respons
uh this that you created being used by
illicit actors. It's of course it's
going to happen because you created
something that is essentially outside of
regulation and also if it's essentially
untraceable then
no big surprise that criminals are going
to use it
because it serves their purposes
a lot better than the regulated systems
that uh the banks are operating or the
the the payment operators. So, and and
this is
it's it's a hard thing to get around
when
what you have is only,
for example, a a decentralized
blockchain. As good as they are in some
respects, they simply are not compatible
with
many of environments that would that you
have to comply with to attract
commercial entities. And this is this
has been our focus to try to figure out
how can we keep the excellent qualities
of a proper blockchain that actually
works properly with
the requirements that actual commercial
operators, real retail operators,
whatever, um cannot get away from
because they actually operate in the
real world with real customers that are
also subject to legislation.
And and one of the things
that ultimately any commercial actor
will want to know is
um if I invest in this, if I actually
commit to using this infrastructure,
am I going to get in trouble legally?
And um actually one of the things that
is getting a little bit scary is if you
look at how the fuzzy liability that
payment providers have now
um means that you can't really be sure.
Then we get into the debanking issues
that actually hit us as well that you
pick some payment operators and
everything looks fine and you've tested
everything and then you open up your
shop and then you get
uh your account gets suspended by the
payment operator on day one and you have
to regroup and it's it's an absolute
disaster.
It's in one sense understandable because
if there is a poorly specified liability
on the payment operator side, yeah, of
course they're going to make a
subjective call.
>> Yeah. They're going to pick the the
lowest risk route forward.
>> Yes.
And sorry, just to bring you back a
second,
>> what was the expression that was used by
the court about willful
>> something acceptance? Willful
acceptance.
>> So,
>> or at least that was the expression
Grock used. So, I'm assuming that that's
>> well, there's there's there's a
contrasting term which is willful
ignorance. um which is that which is
displayed by Christine Lagard and the
IMF when she goes around criticizing
blockchain as being a tool for money
laundering because the reality is on
Groot the opensource governance-free
resource layer that sits at the heart of
Gashimaru
um actually everything is transparent
the same as in Bitcoin an unh
>> an unadulterated
transaction within Bitcoin is entirely
traceable right back from Genesis and So
actually a real an actual blockchain is
an extremely poor money laundering tool.
However, it still doesn't solve the
issue that people are going to have in
the real world of being able to provide
proper accounting, reporting, taxation
um accounts and so on um and to be able
to operate within a compliant framework.
Now,
how things will emerge in terms of the
the ongoing management of fiat currency
or rather mismanagement of fiat
currency, the dilution of human capital
through money printing.
Forgive me. Many of these things are a
bit like Dimitar pointed out earlier,
they are
they're hidden because we don't have a
reference point. You know, he said,
well, what's the alternative? Because a
as things stand, we have two colliding
forces. We have the corporatist agenda
which Jeff Bezos neatly encapsulated
with your margin is my profit. Um, which
is to control everything to have all of
the rent seeking intermediation controls
and to be able to monetize those rent
seeeking positions. And essentially a
rent seeeking position is a place where
you get to impose outsiz costs upon your
users relative to the risk that you're
actually taking which is virtually nil.
And of course the wonderful part of the
duality between the corporatist and the
statist position is that when the
corporatists abuse that so terribly and
thoroughly that the statist will then
bail them out with massive money
printing. We have the global financial
crisis of 2008
in some ways precipitated by poor policy
being driven down from the government
and being pushed onto the the financial
operators. Um, but
when we're looking at these things, the
lack of a reference point has allowed
money printing to go on fairly unabated.
And the transition of that money
printing into our lives is is quite
slow. It's not immediate. Therefore, we
don't have the immediate moment of
walking into the shop and seeing that a
bag of tomatoes is now 20 where
yesterday it was five because there's
now four times more money in
circulation. It takes time for that that
uh to flow through but ultimately real
assets retain their to mark tomarket as
it were value where human capital is
constantly diminished. Um, I'm going off
track here because the point that we're
getting at is that the whole design of
an associate chain framework within the
ripper analogy resource infrastructure,
that's the infrastructure, the resources
group, but the infrastructure layer are
all these associate chains. And the way
that we've designed the Gajimaru is
specifically to allow anybody to come
along and build whatever they want on
the associate chain level. We don't have
any control or governance over that. But
what we expect to happen there is mostly
sovereign actors, large industries,
maybe even just banks come along and say
actually this could provide us with a
really good tool. So if you were a bank
and you wanted to implement a new um
banking system, a new database system
and you wanted to be able to interlink
that with a global currency such as the
Gazu uh and within frameworks that allow
all of that in communication a little
bit like the global layer 1 and I think
you and Dimitar looked at global layer 1
which is an initiative by the monetary
authority of Singapore to create a
framework for the transaction of assets
between different jurisdictions which
funnily when I was listening to the guy
from the Military Authority of Singapore
described this at um point0 in Zurich
last year. I I couldn't help but think
this is, you know, he's saying that
we're going to design the solution set
from a um a paperwork and uh process
perspective, but the technology doesn't
yet exist for us to do this. And I was
thinking, well, actually, the technology
does exist for you to do this. It's
called the Gajimaru. But you two looked
in quite some detail at what global
layer 1 were trying to do um and how
what their ambitions are would be served
by the structure of the gajimaru. So
maybe elucidate some of that because
that feeds into what we're talking about
here. You've got regulated actors within
regulated jurisdictions and each
jurisdiction in their model effectively
becomes an associate chain in ours. It
then has sub subsets within that that
would be the different banks who are
operating with different clients which
could just be SQL databases as we point
out and that is then able to interface
with each other because the native
interoperability is there from group but
the interconnectivity is driven by
choices that each jurisdiction makes as
to how it will operate with other
jurisdictions and what standards which
is not to do with the technology it's to
do with the standards of how something
is described are implemented.
So yeah, we've looked at so many
different solutions so that or ideas
that they tend to blend together. It's
kind of hard to remember exactly
which
competitor was the what. uh as I recall
with global layer 1, one of the big bugs
was
that the assumption was that there is
going to be a very benevolent committee
of course that's going to decide who
gets to uh join
>> like the IMF for example who will
>> the interconnect
and um
and one of the things that
um
what I was thinking
before was also the the thing about what
Dimitar said, what is the alternative?
One of the things that we think that
that I think that Gajumaru
really provides is
a set of technical
alternatives, technical solutions that
actually allow you and really encourage
you to do the right thing. And as
engineers, I think that's
that's about the best you can hope for.
Um because the solution that will try to
force you, force compliance on you is
going to be abused because it's going to
be a magnet for the worst people ever.
And the exact people that you don't want
to fight for control are going to be the
ones to fight for control because you
provided the levers for them. And um and
one of the big things I think for
example we talked about the fuzzy
liability of payment operators.
I guess one one issue there is the
conflation of responsibilities
that
the payment operators that provide
a nice well- reggulated experience in
your local market are also the ones that
provide the global
uh connectivity
of payments. which means that you go the
the card that works so well in your
local market is also the one you can use
in Australia if you ever go there. And
um
and then when
you are both sort of your local
convenience and the global payment rail
and it's very tempting to say for
example when you're launching a war on
terror that hey those payment operators
if we put requirements on them to also
detect all the the bad guys out there
and
and make sure that they cannot use the
infrastructure.
Um I well we can go one step further and
say well you guys you have to be
proactive. We shouldn't even have to
tell you who the bad guys are. You
should detect it. You should shut them
off. That would be more effective. Then
suddenly they are on the hook to
scrutinize everyone
and subjectively
decide who gets to
use their infrastructure.
>> Uh
but it doesn't actually work because
people there are all these rules and yet
trillions of dollars of money laundering
occurs every single year according to
any one of the authorities you want to
point at. Whether that's the UN, the
World Bank or the IMF, they all make it
obvious that something between two and 7
trillion dollars a year are laundered
through the existing banking system. But
>> something you have the uh the issue that
for example the other day it was uh I
saw in an article that Stripe actually
has been building their own layer 1
blockchain.
>> Well, layer 1 is like that thing in
Oprah. You know, you turn up to the
Oprah show and everyone in the audience
gets one. So now the people have worked
out
>> Stripe actually has a control mechanism
with the pretense of decentralization.
Everybody wants one.
>> So Stripe actually has an impressive
portfolio of cryptoreated services. Yet
one of the thing reasons why they may
rugpool you is that your service is
crypto adjacent.
Um
>> did which is just pull us.
>> Yeah.
>> Which is very convenient for them, of
course. Uh and they don't necessarily
have to tell you why they decide to
debank uh actors that are actually
competitors to them,
>> which is where things get sticky.
>> And you were going to say something
there.
>> Yeah. My point is associate chains are
by no means immune to any of those
problems.
uh you can have inflation. So if uh
country A, a national bank of country A
comes and says we're making a soft chain
with our native currency and they decide
to just print more. Uh we as a society
uh have no way of stopping them doing
that. They can do whatever they want. uh
>> we we have no way of stopping them
because as you point out all the tools
all the tooling for building an
associate chain to whatever design the
creator wants it to be is there for them
to do. The interesting thing though
would be that now you would have a
reference point of contrast.
>> Exactly. And since the group is
decentralized and free and it's uh not
subject to any regulation
>> uh it will be stable and inflation free
essentially uh and it will be a the
intermediary between all different
associate chains. So even if someone
decides to print coins native coins not
gumar they cannot print gajumar
uh that will be for their own bio and uh
this is going to have a discipline
disciplinary effect for everyone. Yes,
it will. And this is actually a really
interesting aspect of of the whole idea
of the Gajimar as a as a complete
picture because as you pointed out
earlier, that isn't currently an
alternative. We are stuck dealing with a
fractured, fragmented set of
infrastructures with rent seekers that
run those infrastructures and the
interconnections between them. We are
stuck with central banks printing money
and essentially selling out our futures
for today's convenience. Um, and we
don't see these things because we don't
have a point of contrast. And I think
the really interesting contrast between
Groot and the associate chains
is that that contrast will be obvious
and immediate. If you decide to print
twice as much money today, the Groot,
the Gaju will immediately double in
value against your currency. And this
will be obvious and immediate to
everybody's eyes. So actually the
discipline that it would then force upon
uh sovereign states not to abuse their
citizens is actually a really really
interesting aspect of this whole idea of
the gajimaru. It's on the one hand
respecting the fact that states are
going to want to have their own
structures their own rules regulations
who they want to connect with and how
they want to connect with them and so
on. but on the other to introduce that
which has been missing which is a
reference point that allows the the
populace within that nation to say well
hold on a second what you're trying to
do is actually egregious and we're not
going to accept that because we do have
an alternative it's maybe not as slick
and fast as using the um the SQL
database that is made available to us in
the Republic of uh Catmandeue but
it is something that we can use as an
alternative. So if you start to make the
catmand do dollar uh something that you
just print willy-nilly, we'll start
trading in gajus instead. Thank you very
much. Because the gaju is also native to
every piece of the infrastructure within
the ripper and gajimaru framework. Um
I think it's a topic that we should
actually explore as a as a discussion
hopefully with some other people as well
around this that what what might lead
what might follow from the gajimaru
being implemented and utilized at a
social chain level is that transparency
which is absent from the existing system
and arguably undermines democracy
because people don't have the reference
points to see with their own eyes what
is really happening. So they listen to
CPI and PPI uh consumer price index and
producer price index
news on the TV for example and they
don't really understand because it's
hidden from them what those are the
outcomes of and actually they are the
outcome of money printing but the um the
slowing of that impact into the economy
through the devaluation of human capital
which ultimately ends up trickling into
CPI and PPI. Um
>> yes and um I guess in a sense you could
say that
the
thing that Gajumaru brings to the table
is is sort of free market dynamics in on
in the on the global stage
>> and accountability where
>> through having that contract.
So interestingly just like Dimitar said
uh
providing the ability to
have associate chains being compatible
with regulation.
Every bad example of stupid regulation
will be possible on associate chain as
well. Um what will be hard is to lock
people into having to use that
particular chain.
um it will be harder than it is now. And
uh conversely, on a properly
decentralized
proofof work blockchain like the Groot,
any stupid thing you can do on a
blockchain that regularists don't like
will be possible to do on the Groot as
well. Um
>> yes,
>> possibly unfortunately. But it also
becomes obvious again just as abuse of
the associate chain regulations and
rules becomes obvious so does somebody
acting in a in a deceitful way. The the
old expression and Craig you'll be
familiar with this. If it walks like a
duck, quacks like a duck and swims like
a duck, guess what? It's a duck. Um
yeah, so in the context of tornado cash
and all of the tumblers and actually
just take a moment one of you to explain
I think Dimitar you actually explained
it very well for Peter earlier what a
tumbler is um but all of these things
have as their object purpose the
facilitation of elicit trade because
when they talk about privacy privacy
isn't really what they're trying to to
provide. It may be what they have the
pretense of providing but who is the
actual customer? Um so Demar you
explained earlier to Peter what a
tumbler is so perhaps do it again for
the audience here.
>> I believe that was su but uh essentially
tumbler is exactly what it sounds like.
You put your coins into a common pool of
coins and then anonymously you receive
uh
uh a letter that says that uh you can
withdraw this much from the common pool.
Uh so everyone puts in all the traces
are lost and suddenly different people
withdraw different amounts out of that.
Uh which anonymizes the
well the origin of your coins. Uh
suddenly your coins are freshly coming
from a tumble and nobody knows uh if
they came from illicit activity or
honest activity.
>> Actually you're right. It was Olu who
illustrated it. Forgive me. Um so all
the the way that Dimmitage just
explained it the way we explained it
earlier in summation is uh and actually
my analogy was a tumble dryer that you
you come in with a specific asset which
has a traceable history as in on the
blockchain. It goes into the tumble
dryer with lots of other ones and in a
different channel you share the
information to somebody else that allows
them to claim that value out of the the
tumbleryer.
Um and so the whole thing becomes
anonymous. So actually maybe you should
redo the example you gave earlier for
Peter Santo.
>> So I yeah I guess the part of that was
that the the claim
receipt that you get essentially that I
put in this much that means I can take
out that much but that's anonymous. So
then I can back channel that receipt to
somebody else in an untraceable way and
then they can anonymously claim the the
tokens I put in. And um
yeah and I guess as uh Jarvis pointed
out uh in Australia this whole concept
is illegal actually.
um they have decided to outlaw it
completely. And
I guess the also the tornado cash
verdicts
do illustrate that the
government governments the different
regulated markets they can actually come
after you if you did
in the unregulated space
and they will. Uh there are different
ways that if you're an honest actor who
decides to try that out.
One highly predictable outcome is that
the banks will not touch you with a
10-ft pole, which means you can no
longer do banking, which means you're
essentially shut out from doing business
in the regulated space. And uh this is a
huge problem
overall in the blockchain community.
It's it's it's like it's almost a binary
choice between being reg compliant with
regulation
or just being dark web essentially that
everything everything that's done on
your blockchain is more or less shady.
Um well
>> and this is where I again where I think
we actually provide an an architecture
that
can separate these things. So also as a
user of the gajumaru you can choose
which associate chains you operate on.
you can have a market that runs entirely
on
the assoc chains that are actually
compatible with the restrictions you're
under as say a Swiss citizen or an
American citizen or a Japanese citizen.
Um
and the Groot actually or an unregulated
associate chain could be an interesting
alternative for failed states where
there actually isn't any useful currency
or any useful regulation for that matter
and which is another thing where
blockchain currency can actually be
uh an alternative that actually works
where
uh essentially the existing government
currency is no longer useful.
>> Well, that's
>> because you don't need to be a failed
state. That's pretty much most of the
emerging economies of the world. I mean
the whole thing with Malay and Argentina
was that Argentina had been experiencing
absolutely colossal amounts of inflation
through financial impropriety
u for some time and that's true in many
African and South American and indeed
Asian countries where you've seen
>> massive spikes in in inflation and then
massive collapses in in asset values um
as a result of the nobody having any
faith in the financial system
Coming back to um the whole privacy
thing. So what we've established is that
associate chains provide a tool set for
the existing financial system to work
albeit to work with the control function
of having um a contrast which is an open
free exchange mechanism. Um there is, as
you've alluded to just now, the
alternative that somebody could actually
create an associate chain on the
Gajimaru with no governance and no means
of profiting from that chain that could
provide a privacy function. But
ultimately
it's going to come back to this question
of are they actually providing privacy
or are they in fact facilitating illicit
activity because that's what it seemed
to me uh from the reading that I saw of
the materials you provided about tornado
cashache that was actually at the nub of
the issue. they did have governance
>> and they seemed to be actively
encouraging
um or willful acceptance of where the
majority of that flow was coming from
North Korea and crime. And so I believe
North Korea washed quite a bit of the
money they had stolen as part of their
industrial hacking. Um
Craig, you know quite a bit about that.
Um,
yeah, there's a there's a whole sort of
submarket and so North Korea is
basically banned from doing business
anywhere. So, one way that they can get
they can't do normal trade with most
countries. Um, so one way that they can
get money is by honing what they view as
a militarily uh useful skill, which is,
you know, electronic espionage. Um,
various, you know, various cracking
techniques. It's not always just to to
steal data. Sometimes it's to get into a
control system or whatever. But um in
the course of practicing or or refining
those techniques, they will target a
company uh lock it down and then ransom
them and say you guys can't use your
factory unless you pay us off. But the
way they want to get paid off is they
want to get paid off somewhere that's
external to North Korea because they
need to they don't have money to do any
operations outside of Korea unless they
unless it originates there. So now, of
course, if you just paid money to a
North Korean held bank account, then
it's kind of easy for the State
Department to go, "Hey, that's, you
know, obviously something that we're
going,
>> yeah, we're going to freeze that because
that's easy." Um so instead if they can
get paid in you know if they can get
paid in a form of crypto and that crypto
has a context in which it can be
laundered uh then that works then that
can be converted to fiat somewhere like
way somewhere else um and spent anyway
that North Korea wants to try to fund
foreign operations that they're running
uh like in more hacking. So the hacking
is a self-feeding self in which you're
told you're not allowed to provide
negative feedback. Um but
>> oh that's right. Yeah. Come come visit
North Korea. By the way, negative Yelp
reviews will be prosecuted.
That's like the funniest that's the
funniest little twist that they put in.
But uh anyway, yeah, but that's a big
operation that they do and a lot of par
like if you make this is one of the
problems in geopolitics with creating a
genuine pariah that everybody isolates
is that there's no path back to
normalization and then all the paths to
bootstrap
operation espionage operations become
profitable and that becomes its own
business angle and then they kind of
don't want like the higherups don't
really want to not be a pariah anymore
because they're incentivized to like
double down on this, you know, the crazy
path. So if you push,
you know, if you isolate any country too
much, you wind up getting a split in the
world instead of a temporary
penalization and then rectification. If
you create a genuine pariah, there's no
path normalization back. If you don't
have if you leave no paths of of
redemption open, you eventually alienate
everybody and now you're the pariah. And
that's that's a problem that's
happening. You know, the western
structure is kind of doing that to
itself right now. in weird ways. And it
it's a this is why we when I was in a
weird unit before, we used to always
joke about people that were consumed by
the the delusion of control that you
don't really have control over anything.
Suicide is always an option. So is
failure. And if everybody decides to
fail together in this other direction,
you now are alone. Um so you got to be
careful. of course this is like
geopolitical conversation now but um
that's you know this uh yeah the North
Korean hacker thing that's a real thing
there's a it's not just them um but
that's a self that's a self-looking ice
cream cone of its own
>> well look thank you for that the the the
thing um you touched on there is the
weaponization of the dollar and through
the weaponization of the dollar um
actually its demunition as a global
resource
um if it ever was one, arguably it
wasn't. I mean, if you are Swiss or from
Likenstein, um you will know very well
that the US government uses the US
dollar as a weapon. Uh it has been doing
that for a very long time. If you're
Iranian, you'll know extremely well how
that works. And now the Russians know as
well. The problem is, as you just
identified, is that all of these
different actors as they emerge and
become bigger and stronger commod uh
economies in their own right are
beginning to look at the issue of well,
hold on a second. If I want to go from
Brazil to Russia to do trade, I have to
go from Brazilian uh money to American
money and then American money to Russian
money. um
the the the the communication channel of
value is the US dollar and that can be
shut down at any time on the whim of
whoever's in government in the USA. Um
that perception that this is something
that is being used as a weapon is what's
leading to the conversations about
having a bricks type currency. Now that
conversation is obviously deliluded
because they haven't looked at the euro
and what happens when you have a
unifying currency but no unifying
country underneath it with varying uh
needs and obligations and requirements.
Um
coming back to uh the whole structure of
um associate chains Groot and privacy
what can somebody do in a legitimate way
in order to preserve their privacy in
the context of Groot. So for example, I
have an account with a thousand gaju in
it and I don't really want everyone else
in the world to know anonymized as the
account itself might be uh I don't
really want everyone to know how much
money I have in my account. How might
that kind of privacy that we take for
granted in the current banking system
that we think that nobody else knows how
much money is our account? We ignore the
fact that everybody in the bank does,
but you know, sitting here in the room
today, I would have no means of
inquiring how much money is in Ul's bank
or Dimitar's bank or Craig's bank, nor
they mine.
>> Um,
>> so
>> how might that functional privacy that
we take for granted be accomplished
within the context of blockchain other
than the illegitimate or the adherence
to the existing system? Is there a third
way to unfortunately use Tony Blair's
wording?
In fact, Bill Clinton's as well. They
were both very fond of the third way.
>> Um,
>> and we won't mention Epstein in that
third way either. I can see great.
>> Well, if there is if there is a specific
third way you're uh aiming for it, it
eludes me at right now since I mean
essentially like we said you tornado
cash on Groot as well.
uh because all the expressive power on
that Ethereum
>> that would be illegitimate that that
would be illegitimate and obviously
illegitimate because it has those
governance features. Um but
is I going to be an interesting thing to
see what emerges on Groot? Does somebody
come up with an idea of creating a a
privacy chain that actually is about
privacy and isn't about um money
laundering?
>> Right.
>> So on
creating an associate chain that
implements
some level of of privacy and moving your
gadu there you can do it. um on the
Groot. Well, it becomes a question of
yes, there are technical ways to achieve
it.
They may end up being illegal for the
same reason that tornado cash
uh was criminalized.
>> And it's great. We can't know if they
would become illegal is the trick one of
the tricky and sticky issues here. Yeah,
but if you
>> and it is one of the sticky problems
when regulators are trying to approach
decentralized blockchains, what they
call pseudonymity. It's it's sort of
anonymous but not fully. And as soon as
you can tie an account to a physical
person, then
you can essentially unravel almost all
the activity that is directly or
indirectly connected to that account
until it gets into an exchange.
Uh maybe that's the third way you were
aiming for. The crypto exchanges
essentially work like tumblers because
when you create an account at a in a
crypto exchange,
they own the to that account. So, it's
their account. So, you you graciously
let them have your crypto
>> without the grace of them having any
oversight whatsoever.
>> This is true. So, there is this
wonderful article about Bitcoin. It's
called Bitcoin, who owns it, who mines
it, who's breaking the law. Uh, which I
think gives a pretty good overview of
the um
it it does mention that
um that it's actually a small fraction
of
activity on Bitcoin that's illegal. Um
but it also mentions that about in any
given week 80% of all the the activity
on Bitcoin goes through exchanges
and this is also where uh law
enforcement loses track of criminal
activity because you can trace all the
transactions as long as they are made on
Bitcoin. But when they go into an
exchange, it's essentially a black hole.
It it for enforcement purposes, it kind
of works like a tumbler, like tornado
cash, more or less. And uh
and as long as there is no regulatory
oversight, you don't really know uh if
money laundering is taking place unless
uh something happens like with FDX, they
actually funneled a little bit too much
funds
>> out of the exchange
and then uh the internet called them on
it and the whole thing came crashing.
ing down and then when
that gave legislators a reason to to
look into it because
they had pretended to be a bank but then
failed to deliver on
>> they're all doing that. I mean layer 2s
are essentially custodial banks and
payment service providers uh without the
grace of being regulated as either. What
are they doing? They're expediting
transactions on failed proof of
concepts, Ethereum and now more and more
Bitcoin and they are essentially
creating an intermediary layer again for
all the people who never bothered to
read the Bitcoin white paper and note
even the headline the sorry the title
which is a peer-to-peer economic sorry
electronic cash system not a peerto-
crypto bro to idiot electronic cash
system. Um
what what you're seeing with layer layer
twos and there's an interesting
conversation to have around layer ones
on this as well is that they are using
the pretense of decentralized operations
and smart contracts to uh say that they
aren't doing these things but actually
they are. You do have to trust them.
When you have something like arbitrum
and long cycles to actual settlement the
transactions are very quick but actual
settlement takes days. the opportunity
for malfeasants and error is huge. Um,
so that's that's one part of it. But and
and the layer ones, you know, as I as I
like to point out to people, if someone
were to take the new acts in America and
actually apply them properly, many of
the layer ones would fall foul of
running financial systems that really
the the decentralization is merely a
pretense. Um, and there's quite a few
that you could just list off the top of
your head of which that is true. Um
then around that
you've got this issue as you point out
of exchanges and you know aside from
paying the um the the Trump campaign
hundreds of millions of dollars um to
ensure that you get what you want out of
the system the really
it's as you point out it is really
really
egregious how they operate these things
because you don't actually own anything.
It's mixed funds. I mean, this is
exactly what we learned that in the US
led to the 1934 Security Markets Act,
which was that you can't have blended
funds. You can't mix company funds with
client funds. But that's exactly what
the case is in all of these so-called
exchanges. They're not really exchanges.
They're more like central securities
deposiitories, which in a traditional
financial services context are the most
heavily regulated of them all because
they are almost Genesis.
Um,
>> but they pinky swear.
>> I know, but And they pinky swear with
both hands, too. It's It's um It's
>> Yeah. Like this.
>> Very special. Yeah, it's very special.
Um and and of course part of what uh has
been the reality of especially small
blockchains
is
even if you come up with some really
interesting
how to attract uh users to your
blockchain onboarding is a huge problem
because
if you're not listed on any of the
exchanges
then it's almost impossible to acquire
the currency of your chain to so that
people can start playing with the nice
uh services that you offer.
>> And hold on there. So the the whole
thing with being proof of stake
>> is gameable. We've said this before that
anonymous proof of stake is highly
gameable,
>> but what's actually going in the
background? Dimitar and I think Craig
you both have direct experience of what
goes on with this and Ol I think you've
seen some of it too that the exchanges
play this game knowing that you need to
have some sort of a marketplace on which
your uh fake token is able to um be
traded and transacted and given a value
in the in the terms of something else
rather than its buying power. Um the
exchanges then take very large fees
upfront and all sorts of democations and
and Craig you were talking about back
doors that they try and enforce as well.
I think
>> ba basically they so they'll come out
with a deal that says in the event that
your chain ever has a compromise of any
form whatsoever
you in order to be listed you agree to
reimburse us whatever our losses might
be and re e either just pay us outright
or reset the chain to a safe state. Now,
the whole point of the chain is nobody's
resetting anything.
But that's like a common thing to
request is like, "Oh, you guys will just
fix the state and guide the correct fork
to be the the chosen one." And it's
like, then that's not really
Now, the the crazy thing that like the
light bulb that turned on the first time
I ever saw this, it wasn't one time,
just like every time. Um, but the first
time I saw that, it shocked me that that
could even be a thing that's requested.
It means that it's so common in
different chain projects that they're
essentially permission chains in the
background that that's even a thing that
people ask for that exchanges would ask
for. Um, so yeah, there's some
shenanigans going on.
>> Demand, not ask for demand.
>> Well, yeah. Yeah. Not
>> Yeah. Otherwise,
>> initially you think that you're talking
to someone who simply doesn't understand
how blockchains work.
>> We're actually a blockchain. That is
technically not possible by design. And
then you, oh, okay, that's the way it
should be. But you go, oh, everyone's
just full of crap all the time.
>> Didn't realize that.
>> Silly us who actually designed the
chain.
for everybody in the audience Oprah
style. Dimitar, you without naming
names, you had direct experience of of
seeing this in action.
>> Yeah, we all were there. We all were in
the like and
>> but essentially
they were some exchanges that got burnt
by a non-technical issue for blockchain
and they said you either reimburse us
for our losses so you are taking the
risk for us or uh we stop working with
you and their assumption was that uh
the project has a way of printing uh
coins out thinner, which he didn't, of
course. So, they deleted it almost on
every exchange out there. It's It's
bizarre. It's bizarre how they're doing
business. They're making profits and
expect someone else to take the risk for
them for them not uh being persistent in
their expectations how a blockchain
would look.
>> Go on. Sorry. you you take all the risk,
you give us all the crypto and give us
all the fiat and we pinky swear
this won't go wrong.
That's the deal.
>> This this is what I was going to do.
>> The interesting thing around this is
that we talk about the traditional
financial economic system being
fractured, fragmented uh systems,
platforms interconnected by rent
seekers, operated by rent seekers. But
at least they have the grace of having
somebody theoretically that is
overseeing those operations and that's
what we are really being asked to trust
in that where you see trust you should
see regulation you should see oversight
but what's actually happened in a
context of crypto and let's
differentiate crypto from blockchain
because blockchain as points out is very
very different from what's actually
happening in crypto and the so-called
layer ones and fake blockchains. Um
so
what we're seeing emerge is a huge
number of operators acting in a
completely illicit way where much like
the rent seekers in the traditional
system they want to be indemnified from
any uh loss despite the fact that they
are gambling with other people's money.
Um and they so they transfer all the
risk to everybody else and they seek to
as the expression goes from the global
financial crisis in 2008 privatize
profit and socialize risk except they're
doing it to the chain. It it
it will be very very interesting to see
what emerges because Craig you've talked
about this very well in the past in team
chats about how actually nothing real
has been built in the so-called
blockchain actually crypto world at all
and wouldn't it be amazing to see what
will happen when people wake up to the
gashimaru and understand that now you
can do real business on chain because
all the things we've covered and
discussed are true. You have an open um
resource layer that you can operate in
and that acts as a connective inter
interoperable backbone between
associate chains which can be and will
be in all likelihood operated by consort
of of uh banks, sovereign states as
consorts of different industries and
have at their root purpose the intent to
impose governance and and rules. Um
yeah, over to you.
>> Yeah, the there's so the the basic
problem uh with crypto still is, you
know, I want to buy this cool t-shirt
that I found online. How do I do it? I
want to go down there's a brew or
there's a coffee thing down the road
from my house. I want to go buy coffee
beans with crypto. How can I do that?
Well, you pretty much can't. And so it's
pushed everybody into this funny place
where instead of being digital cash or
even currency at all, it's become while
they've be I mean they've become
gambling chips essentially. They're
we're you know the mechanical horse race
uh gambling it's basically like which
different coin you're holding is your
horse number and it's one of those
mechanical things running around in a
circle and you're betting on it. Um,
that's
kind of what I mean the Ponzicoin game
and the greater fool theory, man,
there's a lot of enormous fools um that
just keep chasing that. And the reason I
say fools is there's no economic outlet
for activity that's real. I can't go buy
a watermelon and pay for it in Bitcoin.
And there's so many practical reasons
why you can't do that. And then on top
of that, there's regulatory ones that
usually don't make it illegal, but they
make it practically impossible. And
that's a very common thing that we run
into with financial wacky financial
rules is that they don't make everything
illegal, but practically speaking,
everything's impossible to do. And
finally, with, you know, the the
commercial focus we have with Gajimaru,
because again, as said, we were like the
naive silly people in the blockchain
world building a real one. Um Whoops.
Uh, I guess the most fascinating thing
is that we've discovered through our own
debanking episodes has been that if your
goal is to go scam a bunch of people
with a rugpool, that's super fine.
There's a there's a path straight to
that. Go for it. You can start up a you
can you can open up
>> it's a welloiled industrial machine.
>> Yeah. It's a that is like
what do they say? The the bullet train
to hell and stairway to heaven. like
it's like you can just hop on the bullet
train and go straight to fartcoin
territory.
Everyone knows how to do it. They know
how to run the hype machine.
Everything's there waiting for you. If
you have any celebrity whatsoever, you
can just do this doing a real thing
though. Oh man, nothing has been built
to do that. Nobody even knows how to
build marketplaces that are backed with
a real blockchain. like the mechanics
behind well we do because we built one
but
there was no like you would think that
with so much money that's flowed through
crypto at some point somebody would have
come along and identified the problems
you know done what we've done built the
new blockchain that's proper that really
works for business and then figure out
what is the what's the structure what
are the what are the patterns that you
have to uncover to to make an online
marketplace actually work with crypto to
make pay at the you know pay at the
counter actually work with real crypto
onchain and I said onchain I don't mean
through some weird intermediary thing I
don't mean that you've given you know
some exchange your fiat and your crypto
and then they're going to in the
background in their database they're
going to do the transaction um that's
the way every every sort of kind of your
paying with crypto solution works right
now um I would have thought that by now
this would be solved and we're finding
that that's not the case where the first
ones doing this. So, what's going to
happen? I don't know. But when people
realize that you could just sell a
bicycle online for onchain crypto and
it's direct to you, there's no
intermediary stuff going on. Um, and
that you realize, hey, I've got this,
I've got I can go buy that bicycle right
now. Um, I don't know what's going to
change, but it's I I don't know what I
don't can't predict the future, but
whatever economic pressure has been
waiting for crypto to become real is
going to be unleashed. And it's going to
be interesting to see what happens.
>> I guess one problem is uh competing
incentives. Uh for example, a lot of
things on blockchain are really tricky
uh from a theoretical point of view. And
uh if you're a crypto researcher,
some of the solutions that we have ended
up with aren't sexy from an academic
point of view. like for example our
associate chain connectors.
I mean if you can do something really
complex with snarks all kinds of weird
zero knowledge proof rollups and man you
can write a number of papers about that.
Um
our associate associate chain connector
points not so much. They are
deliberately simple. Uh partly because
you need to for one thing convince
regulators
that they obviously work as intended
in a way that actually make associate
chains obviously regulatable. That has
been
uh really a core mission for us that it
shouldn't just be possible. It should be
apparent that
it can work. And
soly
that's not quite as sexy. So it's it's
not it's not a very attractive career if
you want to make a name for yourself in
crypto research.
Um,
and
that's that's one of the uh unfortunate
disconnects often between academia and
industry where the stuff that
uh industry solution problems that
industrial engineers want solutions to
are often really
messy in a practical sense, but not
necessarily so sexy. from a theoretical
point of view and actually proving that
they work in the real world is 90% of
the work, but it's not what you get uh
awarded or rewarded for in academia
because it means that you're going to
spend 90% of your time trying to con
convince
the industrial actors out there that
your solution actually works in the real
world. whereas
um and only a fraction of that trying to
publish a paper that's interesting
enough to give you brownie points in
academia.
look to to to bring this home because
you're right in saying that um the
incentive from an academic perspective
is to create complexity and say how
clever am I and have all of your
colleagues go oh you're so very clever
but the reality is clever is not
necessary where obvious and simple will
solve the problem and it's it's that
classic issue. So,
you know, when when I I tend to think in
terms of images as well and um whenever
I think about crypto, the image that
springs to mind, Craig touched on it
earlier, is the deer hunter. And I can't
remember whether it was um Walkan or
Voit that was the one pulling the
trigger playing Russian roulette. But
before it gets to that, you see all
these people gambling with wild passion
over cockroaches racing.
And that when I think of crypto, that's
what I think of a whole bunch of
essentially gambling addicts gambling on
which cockroach is going to win the race
because that's all it is. I mean, if if
you look at what Bitcoin has become,
it's I used to refer to it as Bitcoin
because it was the lord and savior of
number go up, but it it ceased to be a
gambling tool and is now a straight up
open Ponzi scheme. Um, but when you
start looking at all these meme coins
and things, they are literally just
gambling slips where what you're really
doing is saying if I pick up enough
gambling slips on the floor of the the
racetrack, I will find a winning ticket.
Uh, and that's essentially the game
that's being played with these things.
And for some reason, people are actually
engaging this. But when people talk
about blockchain adoption, which is a
different thing from cryptos, I think
we're we're trying to establish,
it's a bit of a desert. There's lots of
projects that have sort of happened but
but failed. I mean, we looked at some of
them. The whole thing that they tried to
do with uh supply chain provenence in in
Walmart in in the states, why are they
failing? They're failing because
actually there isn't an actual
blockchain that actually works that you
can genuinely say I can trust the
message, not the messenger.
And I think the the excitement I have
with the Gajimaru is that we really have
something. It's an actual blockchain
that actually works. Minting real money
that really works. And those that phrase
may sound provocative, but anybody
that's ever told me, "Oh, that's you
can't say that." I've I've challenged
say, "Okay, well, tell me why I can't
say that." Well, because of X. And then
I point out why. Oh, yes, you're right.
And then they point out A and I say,
"Well, what about B?" And you whether
that is anonymous proof of stake being
uh the the essential mechanism by which
you have uh the capacity to collude
between actors and then essentially
decide what something does or doesn't
do. Uh you see that expressed in lay in
so-called layer ones. You see that being
expressed in uh in Dows uh decentralized
autonomous organizations that are not
decentralized and certainly not
autonomous. Um,
it it's going to be really interesting
to see how the adoption of the gajimaru
does exactly what Craig talked about
that there is this latent commercial
desire to use something and we you
talked about this in the last video that
many of the people who've come in to be
early miners are actually
there is this latent desire to break
away from what we have which is this a
set of fractured, fragmented platforms
that are controlled by rent seekers and
interconnected by other rent seekers or
sometimes the same rent seekers
and get toward what blockchain long
promised which is an open base upon
which we can all transact with one
another trusting the message not the
messenger. Um it is going to be
phenomenally interesting to see how that
uh explosion occurs. It it it is that
inflection point that will occur. It's
not when it's not if, it's when. And the
other aspect to it is as you start to
see associate chains emerge because it's
the obvious solution for the
implementation of something like global
layer 1. It's the obvious solution for
somebody to instantiate a national
currency that's a dig in digital form.
Um it's going to be very interesting to
see how for the first time the contrasts
play in that now the individual on the
street can clearly see oh hold on a
second the central bank of catmandeue
has decided to to print more money and
now all of a sudden the gajus in my
wallet are worth twice as much as they
were yesterday why because there's an
immediate trans transition
immediately the world is going to go oh
No, no, no. There's twice as much money
there in that system. So, the value
hasn't changed. It's just there's twice
as much of it. And those disciplines, I
think, are going to be real gamechangers
in terms of trying to restore the
context that we have taken for granted,
that we live within a liberal democracy
and that these things are all working
and there's proper accountability. And
what we've been discovering, especially
for the last 25 years, I'd argue, is
that there's very little real
accountability. Um, any closing thoughts
from any of the three of you on all of
the above?
>> Um, that last bit there about
>> Sorry,
>> go ahead Craig.
>> Oh, the that last bit about So
there's all these potential uses of
blockchain because it's a distributed
ledger technology. the distributed
ledger use itself has been explored
somewhat by industry and none of those
projects have worked out. Um the problem
with all those projects, the the reason
that they never work out isn't because
they make a bad chain or whatever. It's
because the currency
of those chains, if those chains are
only used for uh for ledger purposes,
the currency on the chain that's
supposed to make it work, has no
economic outlet. So it's not actually a
currency. So you're not staking anything
if you're in if you're in an industrial
chain where every actor in your industry
has to stake some certain amount of
whatever the coin is. Uh so that so
that's your your penalizing factor if
somebody becomes a bad actor and now all
the shippers are going to uh agree to
log providence and transfers and so on
on the same shared ledger. If you're
going to do that, you have to have real
money that you can go buy shoes with to
be the penalty bearer. You can't just
use some madeup token whose only utility
is being a staking coin. That doesn't
make any sense because that staking
coin's got no reason for being aside
from just being a stake thing. So, you
can be a bad actor and trash the coin,
be like, I don't care. I couldn't buy
anything with it anyway. Well, that all
changes when the Gaju is that's why the
Gajju is carried by all associate
chains. So just you were talking before
about the hierarchy of chains, there is
a hierarchy, but it's only in the
context of each currency. And as we've
discussed already, you can have
multicurrency chains. So the pinnacle of
some other currency chain structure
flows towards wherever the meant for
this other thing is. Um because they're
all tied together by the gajju though.
If you were to create a staking chain,
an associate chain, it's a staking
chain. It's not anonymous staking. It's
known actor staking. The operators are
they put up stake to become operators.
That may be part of an internal industry
agreement to you know make sure that
nobody can go back and backdate fake
serial numbers on car parts or something
so nobody can counterfeit them in the
future. It that works if they're staking
because mean something because they have
an economic outlet elsewhere. So that
all changes things radically. that
changes the whole proposition uh with
regard to these you know the the ledger
uses the data ledger uses of blockchain.
So we don't know where that's going to
go but that's a thing that will open up
also all this kind of unravels by
actually simplifying things and saying
let's get back to having a currency be
like a currency and then if that's true
all these other things that have been
theorized also suddenly become true and
available. Um, I I think this is going
to be interesting. This is like this is
going to be really cool. We can actually
open this technology up properly. Um,
but the whole the missing piece was that
I can't just go buy shoes with crypto
yet
>> and therefore there's no real penalty to
my actions. It's all
>> Yeah. That's all just
>> and and um I you could add I guess that
the step towards
uh making an associate chain that's
actually compliant with regulation the
main part I guess could be that if you
are already an actor who
meets the requirements in this space
Say you're a bank. You have all the
infrastructure in place, all the
routines in place to be compliant with
uh regulation.
The
the thing that the associate chain gives
you is that all the moving parts are
under your control. So for example,
transaction selection in blocks, if you
run it as a permission chain,
uh what would be needed as an addition
compared to say the group? softwarebased
is you will use a different uh
transaction selection filter where you
could actually say do blacklist checking
whatever and deny certain transactions
that don't meet the criteria whatever
they may be. Maybe you have a
requirement that all accounts should
provably belong to actual citizens in
your country or something then that is
easily verifiable. The design choices
filter you apply
>> the design choices around that interface
with Groot are fundamental to how the
whole thing would work. You you dictate
what you will accept in and what you
will allow to go out and how you will do
those things.
>> The hard part is clearing the bar as an
actor that has uh earned the trust of
the finance inspection within your uh
economic market.
>> I'm not so sure about that actually. I
think um if you look at how banking
>> at least there's a bootstrapping thing.
>> Yeah. But if if you look at how um how
banking technology stacks work the there
are this code in there from the 1970s.
Um, I remember talking to a consultant
on financial uh systems from IBM and he
showed me uh a transa sorry a a a
polling map of all the different servers
that were pulled in order to provide one
simple statement to a customer on their
mobile phone. How much money is in my
account? Um, and there were 27 different
uh servers that were pulled in order to
get that data and present it correctly.
And it blew my mind because it really
made me realize just how
how cumbersome the existing financial
infrastructure actually is and how
the banks talk about that infrastructure
being a core asset, but I actually think
it's a core liability and it's an
ongoing liability that everything else
has to compensate for.
Um, so actually the whole thing of
associate chains, yeah, I think it does,
but I think the whole thing of associate
chains,
>> if you're talking to a regulated actor
who wants to be who really wants to make
a step change, their capacity to build
denovo on an associate chain linked into
Groot is actually such an attractive
option because all of a sudden you can
embrace the transparency
albeit that you put the cover of well
we're regulated entity we're trusted by
our customers we are regulated by a a
proper regulator of global standing and
on that basis we're then going to run
effectively a state channel within that
system and I think that opportunity is
massively massively attractive if the
big financial actors were to understand
it because it would mean that they could
leave all of that legacy architecture
behind.
Dimitar, anything to add before we
close?
>> Oh, I don't think so. You're really,
really
into details.
>> Okay, with that, thank you very much
everybody. We'll see you again next
week. Bye-bye.